the film business loves to put people in
boxes you got to play someone who just
had a car crash because you're in a
wheelchair here it's like you don't have
that
[Music]
the dream is to change the way
disability is seen in America there's so
much talent and you see it here with
this group on Iowa healthy and I'm one
of the directors of Zeno Mountain Farm
and I'm Peter Harvey another director
that's you know our mission is to
support lifelong friendship an
opportunity for people with and without
disabilities it's important for us to
have the integration we run camps all
year long and right now we're at our
film camp we make movies for about 12
years now we've done all different types
of genres from a sports drama movie we
did a time travel movie we did a
superheroes movie a Western and this
year we're doing a high school musical
the last film we did we went to film
festivals all over and the hope is that
we get to do that with this every aspect
of this film we have disabled talent
from the casting to the lighting to the
script writing
no Dale James baby Bedell Noah and the
second AC good sound I'm an actor I love
being in movies we have two really
exciting weeds for this movie Ricky and
Roxy go for Roxy hi my name is Ricky
Wilson jr. I'm playing Tony Michaels hi
my name is Roxanne Hubert ha and I'm
playing sage you guys ready it's roll
music the film is basically about two
teenagers who go to summer camp and they
fall in love it's sort of an homage to a
lot of the classics such as grease but
means
all the disability just fades away here
and everyone's just a person in outside
films world disability has to be written
in the story people have to know why my
character sage it's never discussed why
she's in a wheelchair and I think that's
so awesome it's incredible everyone's
just beaming constantly this is their
lives they live for his you know and you
can feel that we're here
in the disability world there's there's
this isolation there's this lack of
opportunity that exists as you know
everyone understands each other wants to
connect and find the talent and everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
in Saskatoon Saskatchewan you'll find
for senior citizens making socks lots
and lots of socks talks by Bob have
knitted eleven thousand six hundred and
sixty-two as of today that's pairs of
socks which means socks by Bob has
knitted twenty-three thousand three
hundred twenty four individual socks
eight point eight miles of socks and
they're all for charity the main
responsible for all these socks is none
other than Bob Rutherford enter bob's
knitting machines these super powered
knitting machines go at ninety turns per
second that's pretty fast but what makes
these machines special are that they're
self-made I'm an experimenter I just
build things and it took a long time to
figure out how to do it but when you're
retired and nothing to do it just sort
of grew socks by Bob began in 2010 after
the passing of Bob's wife Edith I was a
caregiver to my wife before she died and
my son came home and said dad you need
something to do I said well I made these
socks on this first knitting machine and
that sparked an idea making socks for
those in need but Bob doesn't work alone
he has plenty of help George cuts the
couglink
Glen and Barney who runs the tube socks
Barbara rule each week Bob and his team
made hundreds of socks that they then
deliver to countless homeless shelters
all throughout Canada when fox are
delivered in Alberta Saskatchewan BC Red
Deer Calgary some of glowny to the
northern program
and sharp they go to where they're
needed people gotta keep involved you
just can't give up because of the
bereavement or whatever the case may be
I think the mending socks for needy
people is important people have to reach
out and touch each other I think that
they go over and this has helped me do
that and I think that's the key to life
you don't give up and find the purpose
find something that needs to be done and
do it
[Music]
normally there's this awkwardness around
disability but with that costume on
there that changed how people saw my son
they saw him first before they saw his
disability
it just helps break down that barrier
[Music]
magic wheelchair is a nonprofit that
builds epic costumes for amazing kiddos
and wheelchairs magic wheelchairs
started when my son was 3 years old
Halloween rolled around and he wanted to
be a pirate we're new to the whole
disabilities and wheelchair thing we
didn't know anything about spinal
muscular atrophy I saw him sitting in
his wheelchair how we could dress them
up as a pirate be a pirate in a
wheelchair and let's let's build a ship
we have made probably about 40 different
costumes we have teams right now all
over the country we have a team in
France and working on a team in
Australia we're just gonna keep on
boarding teams because we want to build
year round it's harder to build for
people that are in wheelchairs but it
ultimately starts with the kid it's
whatever they want to be and then we
make it a reality
[Music]
Halloween was kind of our initial push
but we're seeing like comic-con right
[Music]
and what's cool about that community of
cosplay that's a very supportive
community the the cold reality of
childhood diseases are some of them
won't be around for next Halloween
so let's find something that we can do
while they're here with us so they have
these that they have these great
memories and that they're there our
families have memories when they're gone
[Music]
it's almost like a cure for the day
because they don't see the wheelchair
they just see these amazing kids and it
bridges gaps and overcomes that
awkwardness that we have in society I
mean their star the show oh it's awesome
to see
[Music]
[Music]
there's so many reasons why I do what I
do I love surfing and I love helping
people I think if everybody found what
they love to do what they were designed
to do and use that gift to help others
there's a world would look so different
[Music]
my name is Lambert Lowe and I'm a surf
instructor I was living in Hawaii living
the dream teaching surfing to
billionaires and celebrities at the end
of the day something was missing and I
knew in my heart that I needed to come
back to where it all started I grew up
in California the ocean was where I felt
the most connected they came back and
started a nonprofit called the mix
Academy
[Music]
one of the things that come out of the
mix Academy is this surf school and I
brought that gift of surfing here with
some of the people that need the most
smiles my current class consists of a
refugee from North Korea Nathan a
nine-year-old who is visually impaired
and Shannon a veteran going through
alcoholism school of the misfits is a
place where you can belong on land
everyone looks at us a little
differently but when you're in the water
the water washes all that off surfing
like life is full of ups and downs
there's waves that are coming you can't
stop that from coming pain is gonna come
what you can't control is yourself and
how you're gonna react
you can choose to paddle for it embrace
it adapt to it and enjoy the right or
this waves gonna come and it's gonna
knock you out and it's gonna like you
out pitching the wave was a great
feeling
helping others catch their first wave is
a greater feeling to watch that smile
just ear to ear and knowing that yeah
that's gonna change someone's life
[Music]
walking around a refugee camp you just
see rows and rows of tents the trauma
that these people have experienced is
just so severe and life consuming so I'm
bringing dance to this refugee camp as a
therapy tool
[Music]
this camp is filled with refugees who
have had to flee their homes because of
Isis this displacement has really just
taken everything including their will to
even try because of the hopelessness
that comes from being a refugee
I'm studying dance at Belhaven
University but I've always been really
interested in how dance can be taken off
the stage and that's when I really began
to see a greater scope with dance and
that maybe it could be used for
something more than just myself when
this opportunity came about for me to
volunteer at the center as a dance
teacher I really just couldn't resist
these children's desire to move is so
great they just took the class in there
was laughter and smiles immediately
regardless of language barriers we use a
lot of motion and a lot of pointing and
arrows and directions and we communicate
with our bodies dance is this really
amazing vessel for which healing can
take place because it involves
physicality and connecting with yourself
in your body that's kind of a missing
piece there's a lot of focus on your
mind and your thoughts and your emotions
and then sometimes the body is left out
sometimes we label refugees as refugees
and that's all that they are but they
have the same needs that you and I have
to be creative and to move and to
breathe and to engage with their
humanity I think having a creative
outlet within a camp is so necessary
because it's not only fulfilling those
needs for food and shelter but also
fulfilling that need for them as human
beings
[Music]